so hi everyone my name is Ophir
this talk was supposed to be I have a
co-conspirator to this and unfortunately
he couldn't make it tonight so I will no
think he's parts of the presentation but
he was wanted to apologize this is me
I run the newsroom i run the data
science team at horn works and my
co-conspirators Jiwon so at least you
can see who he is is a PhD at Stanford
actually just started working at
Pinterest and he designed this package
called socialite for graph algorithm
that we're going to talk about tonight
as well and it's why we kind of started
to work together on this project so what
I'm going to talk about is why is for
detection important in healthcare as
George mentioned this is about anomaly
detection fraud detection is where we
looked at this but it could be applied
in a broader sense in healthcare you
have things like overpayment detection
they talk about all kinds of things
they're not just somebody committing
intentional fraud right so there's a
little bit of a difference there so I'm
going to talk about why it's important
I'm going to try to talk to you about a
little bit of describe the Medicare B
data set that's a data set that we use
for this particular use case I'm going
to talk about similarity and PageRank
our approach to this in high level and
I'm going to show you some of the code
in some of the highlights of the
approach we took and some results now
all this will be in github so you can
take a look at it later we don't have to
write notes and kind of photograph the
code if you don't know if you can but
you don't have to so I want to give you
a heads up that it's already and the
slides will be shared later on so with
that let me start and talk about why why
it's important so healthcare is a I
don't know if some of you may not know
it's it's a huge industry it's it's
trillions of dollars right so the total
expenditure is like you know two point
what is it something like almost 2.5
trillion dollars in the US alone and in
Europe it's you know almost a I think a
trillion or maybe well less than that so
huge industries and so fraud is a
percentage of that so for example and
these are estimates the estimated amount
of fraud only not over
payment just fraud is 171 billion
dollars that's that's estimated right so
if you if you improve it a little bit of
that it's it's worth for a while this is
this is a big problem to solve right so
and the estimate is that the the amount
of fraud that people recover different
companies recover through their systems
that they have is still pretty low it's
just them it would be you know eight to
ten percent and this is like three or
four percent so there's still a lot of
work to do and that's why this is a
worthwhile problem to give you a couple
of examples I picked this up by Google
around a little bit to show a couple
examples but there's a doctor billing
too often for the most expensive office
visits right so you see in a row that
they always have there's three types of
office visits the cheap one the middle
one and they're always having the most
expensive one so that's a something
you'd investigate why that happens right
there's another really interesting
example where a medical supply store
they have these wheelchairs and they
have the expensive one it cost like
seventy five hundred and they have a
cheap one it cost like I think was
fifteen hundred or something and they
colluded with the doctors they said hey
the doctors you you prescribed the
expensive one will deliver the patients
the cheaper one they wouldn't know the
difference and it will make them so
there's a lot of money to be adding very
very complicated schemes and you be you
know Sodom or whatever there's a lot of
money people find creative ways to do
these kind of things unfortunately so
when people try to identify these things
they usually look at different patterns
and similar these are some of the common
patterns that we see in the industry
today people just look for rules and
they look for rules around things like
upcoding
billing more expensive services they're
perform they're looking for people
perform unnecessary services on patients
just to get money right people I mean of
course complete fraud is you billed for
services that were not actually
performed so there's a lot of things
around how a doctor or a provider of
different sorts can you know bill an
insurance company to get to get money
back and which is far low so there's a
lot more other things and I don't want
to get too much into the details of that
but I wanted to tell you about most
health care providers do what they
have in place is they have a couple of
different systems to detect this but
mostly it's based on rules they have all
kinds of rules and they say you know if
the if the claim is above a certain
number of this type then it may be
checked or if if there's too many you
know if a person has this disease and
they give this other procedure you check
that so there's a lot of different rules
like that and of course some companies
started doing some machine learning
based things so they build supervised
learning models essentially to detect
this fraud and they provide features for
this model and they put this in a
supervised learning framework to run
whatever random forest or something and
they figure out what the fraud is and
that's how they do it and some of the
features that you can see our you know
claim features so of course those are
the easy one right you have a claim it's
a certain amount the amount of money the
procedure whatever those are probably
came to claim features there's provider
features those would be things about the
doctor or the nurse or whatever the
provider of the service like where they
live or the average number of claims
that they've done in the past three
months or whatever things like that and
they all have patient features things
about the patient so all these come into
this machine learning model and the
reason I'm telling all of this is
because our approach is we're going to
generate a new type of feature or a new
types of feature or set of a family of
features we're not gonna I'm gonna show
you a technique here that's going to
replace your existing fraud systems I'm
gonna show you a technique that adds a
new feature type that probably doesn't
exist in existing ones and hopefully
it'll it'll give you a better result
overall from from fraud detection and
the reason we looked at patients by the
way because you know supervised learning
is getting a lot of attention and I
think a lot of people are very
interested in in graph algorithms but I
found personally that in my you know
tours around the country and talking a
lot of our customers is that people
really like graphs but they don't always
know exactly what to do with them right
like I build a graph I know doctors are
tied to nurses and to patients and to
diagnosis but then how do I take it the
last mile how do I use it in algorithm
to do something that's supervised
learning or something like this it was
not really clear and
like I felt it wasn't clear enough and
so I went on this mission to sort of try
to show at least one example of how to
do that
so this is really the goal of this of
this approach okay
specifically I'm gonna show you we're
gonna produce new features that are a
score coming from the PageRank algorithm
that reflects how much each provider is
anomalous in the context of the
specialty so if you're a doctor that's
like a cardiologist right and you seem
like you're not a cardiologist that'll
be the anomaly we're gonna try to detect
I'm going to explain how to do that in
the next few slides let me talk about
the data set Medicare B is a data set
that's available it was mean it's been
released by the CMS which is the
Medicare organization in 2014 it's got
about 9.5 million records about eight
hundred and eighty thousand providers of
different kinds and a lot of CPT's
procedure codes and it includes all the
payments that medicare made to providers
in the year 2012 aggregated in some way
the reason this is useful because
there's no real other data sets
available out there if you want to do
something in medical research you're
really hard to find this type of data so
I was very happy to find this type of
data that I could actually use and so
we're gonna look it's got a lot of
fields in every record we're gonna use
four of those the NPI
which is the national provider
identification that's the doctors ID
we're going to use the specialty it's a
string that says this is the specialty
of the doctor we're gonna use the cpt
code that's a procedure code for the
medical procedure in this record and
then there is another we're gonna use
count which is the number of procedures
performed particularly in this
particular year who could have used
other things like maybe the amount that
they asked to be paid or the amount they
got paid which sometimes different but
this this turned out to be the best the
best thing to use and I'll explain more
how we're using it in a second this is
what it looks like right so this is a
typical record where's my mouse here you
can see the NPI the provider I didn't
actually they have other things like the
name of the
and this is just example the top five
records here internal medicine you know
what they did and here's some of the
counts see there's different ways they
count the number of procedures during
the year and so each of these records
and we only take you know these four
records like I explained right so that's
pretty simple now here's our approach
one we're gonna do some data preparation
we ended up finding that some of this
data needed some cleaning up not too
much but just you know every data
science project ends up having something
like this then we're going to compute
similarities we're gonna build a graph
from that and we're gonna use a variant
of PageRank to compute some PageRank
scores that will give us this anomalous
scores okay so let's look at step number
one well it's very simple
on a base level well we just have to
extract the relevant fields that's
that's a pretty pretty simple select but
we found out that some of the specialty
strings that we had in dataset were
actually wrong so we looked up a couple
these doctors not a lot but we found it
out after we ran the whole thing that
some of these specialty codes were
actually old like a doctor might change
their specialty and go to and
investigate some other field of
expertise or something like this so we
had to do a little bit of cleanup for
our technique to work the way we did it
we we looked up there's a data set the
public data set called NPI data
it's the where the NPI registry has the
data we looked it up
so we mapped the NPI to a specialty code
and then we use the under one nu C C to
map the submission in the code to a
specialty string we cut corner a little
bit because some doctors might have more
than one special thing which just took
the top one but again this is just a
demo so we it's not working in
production and any companies we just
wanted to kind of make it simple but in
real life you might have to consider all
the specialties but that's kind of the
cleanup that we did so pretty simple
step one step two I'm sorry is we want
to build a graph by similarities so
here's what we do so consider two
providers and let's say we represent
each provider each doctor by a vector of
the the CPT codes the procedure codes
that they have so this is about 6,000
CPT codes so if you have these
this vector if you're like cardiologist
you probably have some counts on the
procedures that cardiologist does and if
you're a dermatologist you'll have some
other place so two doctors will look
very similar that means they're probably
the same specialty or very close but you
know very close in a specialty to each
other so we kind of have this notion of
doctors are similar to each other
if their representation as a vector of
CPT codes is looks the same or has a
similarity and we of course use Thank
You Casey for introducing that with the
cosine similarity here again it actually
is a good thing to do here in this case
so each provider is represented as a
vector of these 5900 cpt codes and we
compute similarity okay now this is a
five length vector just to show but can
I here's how it looks right so this
these two doctors actually look pretty
similar because they have four shared
and one that's not shared right so
generally that's kind of how it works
pretty pretty straightforward the
problem is that this is really difficult
to do at large at large scale because we
have about let's call it I mean eight
eight hundred and eighty thousand let's
call the million providers so you got a
trillion similarity computations right
it's a pretty big problem and and each
similarity computation is also not you
know vectors of three it's vectors of
six thousand so it takes a while to
compute this so you can compute this on
your own but we decided that's where we
kind of decided to use Hadoop for this
so we wrote a big script and we did some
heuristics to do that first we only
compute similarity between two NPI's if
they're if they share their most
prominent CPT code so we we look at what
are the CPT codes that are very very
high up on their list they have most
count highest counts and if two doctors
share one or more of those CPT codes
then we compute similarity between those
two doctors and if not we don't and then
we filter out NPI's or doctors they have
less than three CPT codes because
similarity is not meaningful with two
it's just it's too little information so
kind of have this little ad hoc but
really the gist of this is we use the in
this particular case pay what could have
used a bunch of other things with some
UDA
to compute this and distribute this
computation across the cluster because
it's not it's it's easily distributable
you can you know you can write it a lot
faster if you run it on on a big cluster
so that's one we're one thing I'm going
to show you in a minute I want also to
mention that there are alternatives to
doing this dim sum and LSH and I want to
just mention those if you're interested
you should look at those as well
dim sum is a it's something that came
out of research it was done I think in
Twitter about computing similarity at
scale using a MapReduce a very
interesting probabilistic technique
using MapReduce I was somebody at
Stanford and and Twitter and then spark
has an implementation of that so if you
want you can use that the other one is
locality sensitive hashing so data foo
which is a library of Pig of UDF's in
pig has a locality sensitive hashing
implementation and locality sensitive
sensitive hashing can also be used to do
this a little bit more efficiently again
all these techniques are probabilistic
in a sense that you you compute
similarity you lose some of the more
exact similarities but you get it to run
faster so this is the code in pig and I
intentionally made it really small
because I don't want it I don't intend
to explain it if you if you want you can
go to the web to the the website and I
just want to show that it's not three
lines of pig it's a little more
complicated I didn't want to highlight a
couple of things if you go out and read
that code yes
and the similarity communication is
based on the normalize the data do you
normalize the acrosses
procedure oh it's just with the
procedure actually we don't know you
mean normalize the vectors yeah we
actually did not normalize the vector we
just computed Imel arity directly yeah
based on the counts yes yes we did we
did some data cleaning at the beginning
but uh normalization but it's a good
actually we didn't we used directly but
the other approach we we were gonna try
was just log of the counts instead of so
I'm normalized to some to one but just
log the counts to make it more
meaningful I mean I think if you
implement this in a real world you can
try the different approaches to see
which one works best but we didn't know
I think you meant normalizing the
vectors to some two to be a norm two of
one right yeah we didn't do that in the
code but it's it's it's something you
can try as I agree yes
it was still pretty pretty large so
actually it's one of the points I want
to talk about here so it's a good
lead-in one of the problems was still a
lot of really large skew so a lot of the
doctors end up being with your stick
number one they end up being in the same
cluster that I need to compute this guy
against all these other people and this
person against all these other people so
you have these really big clusters of
doctors that are very that are
supposedly very similar to say that are
fall into the Aroostook and then you
have smaller clusters so you have to I
had to do a bunch of tricks to actually
redistribute the computation randomly so
they did you don't have one of the nodes
on a cluster get a really a set of
really large clusters to compute and
then some of the other nodes finish
earlier and we all wait for the ladder
node but it was still pretty large so
the huge stakes helped a little bit but
they didn't like shrink it by like 10 X
or anything like that though it was it
was maybe half or something you know
like something like that let me finish
I'll pause after for questions about
piggy for a move to the next one but the
things we did was we just replicated
joins videos who know I mean in Pig like
in hive we have kind of broadcasts
replicated Jones which are very helpful
a lot of these this script had a lot of
small tables for to map you know the cpt
codes to to indexes and things like that
so we used that we used we did a data
skew handling which I talked about so
some of these things here is reshuffling
the data to make sure it's skewed
randomly across the cluster to make it
more efficient and also we use Python
UDF's to compute similarity and break
large clusters into smaller ones why
Python just because I you know I happen
to like Python at that point in time but
you could have done it with Java or
anything else if you want it it's it's
just the convenience that's all so again
this this code is available on github
you can take a look at it as well as the
PI everything with the Python UDF so you
can take a look at it let me pause here
if there's any more questions for a jump
in at a graph patreon category is in
part all right so so PageRank as you
guys and girls probably all know is is
the the original algorithm that was used
that
Google to do a ranking of webpages right
there is a version of it called
personalized PageRank and personalized
PageRank is is a variant that we used
that it's also called topic sensitive
page week and our approach is we're
gonna compute a specialty centric
personalized page rank for each node so
we take the graph that we had before so
the graph is you know if you had you had
similarities and so if the similarity
was above a certain threshold would draw
an edge between two nodes the nodes are
doctors or providers and will have an
edge between if it was above let's say
85 or 0.85 or something like this so
it's a it's an undirected graph so if
you connect to the doctor your similar
on both sides and well one I get if you
want to get this score the score on each
node and this score will be the score
we're gonna use to tell you if it's
anomalous or not related to this
specialty so it's a specialty centric
personal page rank and an anomaly
candidate will be somebody that has a
really high score but it's not of that
right of that same specialty so if
you're a cardiologist and you have a
really high score on dermatology
something's wrong with that that's kind
of what we're after in an intuitive
sense so a quick overview of PageRank or
well I I did this here with doctors
although the original one of course is
with web pages but you got these these
all these doctors right and the way you
think about PageRank is is as a random
walk on this graph so imagine a random
walker somebody would start randomly
from one of the nodes and at every point
in time they would do one of two things
the other go to an adjacent node with
equal probability to the number of nodes
so if you're if you're doctor Chang you
can go with 50% to dr. Padilla and 50%
to dr. yang okay or with and this is you
do this with 80% probability with 20%
probability you teleport or you randomly
jump to a random node in the graph okay
so not telling you probably anything new
here this has been around for for many
years and that's the traditional
PageRank and it's been used for many
years and there's very efficient ways to
to compute this and what you see in the
probabilities here are after it
converged if you do a law like infinity
number of these steps or at convergence
you get some probabilities on each node
and those are present the likelihood
that if you do this random walk you
would end up in one of these nodes so
clearly doctoring is more likely that
we're gonna end up more likely to end up
here than to end up here right that's
what it means
now personalized PageRank is we start
with a particular specialty in our case
that's that's how we kind of translated
it so imagine if you start with a
specialty let's say it's cardiology that
the red specialty right and so what we
do the difference is you do the same
kind of random walk but you start from
random node and step zero that's in your
specialty group so you've started one of
the red nodes and when you teleport
you're only allowed to teleport into one
of the red nodes as well right so when
you move through the graph that Jason
notice all the same but when you
teleport you can only go back to one of
these nodes okay and you know if we
chose a different specialty and like the
blue one then it will look differently
and what happens is you get the
specialty gets special treatment of
course because you can all the teleport
to those same nodes and so they get
higher scores right so this is why it
actually matches with what the intuition
we had which is if your doctor Padian
which is you have a red specialty but
you end up having a really high score
it's probably something is something's
wrong and this is the intuition is also
because you know these doctors remember
the special the similarity that we have
is these are all let's say
dermatologists right they all look the
same they should look the same that it
should be very well connected and so
they won't be very very connected with
the cardiologists because they don't
have the same CPT codes so this is kind
of how this this thing finds it right so
we we ran this this thing now in order
to rise personal space rank we use this
package called socialite that I
described in the beginning this is the
package that g1
created with a couple of collaborators
and Stanford and his PhD project and
it's a open source again available
online we actually included a any kind
of a snapshot of that in the gate
so you can use the exact version that
worked for us but I think there's a
newer version already on the website so
there's a lot of graph algorithm
packages or giraffe and graph lab and
things like that
the nice thing that I found about
socialite is that you don't actually
have to write code in a traditional
sense like if any of you tried giraffe
it's like I want to write I want to
think like a node or think like your
vertex and you have to you have to
re-implement the algorithm in a clever
way based on their programming model
what happens here is you it's almost
like like sequel for graphs it's like
you write the code in a sort of a
rule-based a warm what needs to happen
and socialite converse this into an
executable the runs and implement this
algorithm so in this case if I can run
through this a little bit to explain how
this works right so we this is part of
the code but we we this this line says
let's create a table that that has the
following columns NPI iteration and rank
which is the page rank this is the score
and I'm going to initialize it with zero
for everybody on on iteration zero
that's by default and for those who are
part of the source NPI's those are the
specialty NPI's if it's in a specialty
NPI then it's going to be one divided by
and being the number of specialty
doctors so I'm kind of initializing it
here and then I do and we found the ten
iterations was enough we tried a couple
numbers and it converges after ten
pretty quickly but what you do is you
say okay and this is if you think about
it this is almost like the equation of
page rank is I say with twenty percent
probability I'm going to I'm going to go
to for iteration I plus one I'm going to
look at one of the source nodes remember
this is the teleport part with twenty
percent probability I'm gonna go to one
of the source nodes and with eighty
percent probability I'm gonna go to any
node in the graph and so you can write
this little thing with you know
relationship between between different
parts of the graph and that's all you
have to do to implement special you know
personalized pager so it's pretty cool
the nice thing about social ideas is
that you can have it in the next slide
is PageRank here's our three lines of
code that's it everything else gets it
interprets this code it creates a very
efficient implementation underneath and
and runs it for you
it also integrates nicely with Python
which is really nice so in here you can
see some of these variables like I is a
Python variable but you can reference it
inside the the socialite code so
anything under these back takes is sort
of socialite code so but you can you can
you can kind of interrelate between
python and socialite and then you don't
have to think like you know it's more of
a declarative language you can just
describe what you want and get it done
so that's that's kind of the end of the
implementation so we got this course and
lastly I just wanted to emphasize again
that this is not replacing an existing
system the idea is that if you have a
machine learning system like I described
in earlier this is a visual way of
located you got a claim coming in
learning features from patients from
providers from the claim itself you have
these features you run your frog now
when you maybe fit it into a rules and
you make a decision all we're saying is
take those take those features we
generate with the page rank and feed
them into as another set of features so
each you can run this algorithm one time
for specialty generate a number per
provider and if the provider here is X
you pull that number you put it into
your model and you get a better a better
result that's the idea all right
two examples and now I'll let you ask
questions this is because we didn't have
an actual fraud system to check this out
we did the best we could do in spite of
that to try to at least see manually
that this looks okay so what it is we
looked at a couple of examples where you
know we found somebody with a particular
specialty that didn't seem to belong
there that had that had become had a
high score and another specialty group
right so here's an example of
Ophthalmology sorry I don't know in
can never pronounce this so
ophthalmology I think is is it ent I
sorry I doctors I should have known
right eye exams right this is this is
the codes that you have so so we found
an internist somebody internal medicine
who had all these codes so again
important for me to say that I I'm not
saying this this person we found an
internist is necessarily a fraudulent
person but it is weird that somebody
like that will have so many I I related
CPT codes and therefore it's more likely
that a person might be fraudulent so you
put it into the model on you you figured
like that so that person had a high
score when you ran in an internist kind
of specialty model the second one is a
plastic surgery we ran it on plastic
surgery when we find a couple of
different things that look like they are
Casey's Auto Loranger that's C and T
right there you go
so you'll find an ENT person who did a
lot of stuff that looked like plastic
surgery right so that's again suspicious
these are the kind of things that you
get out of its algorithm and you feed it
into if you don't score into into the
model sorry
yes these are these are for plastic
surgery right so skin lesions as much as
usually well I'm not a medical doctor
maybe maybe those are okay but those are
ger then find that those appear more
often in plastic surgery some ents might
do this once in a while I mean I'm again
this is a statistical probabilistic
algorithm it's not a very precise rule
right that's kind of date that key to
this but what we found is that you take
the score you don't have to do what we
did here you just take the score and you
put it into a model and if the core
becomes interesting from a supervised
learning model then it's a really useful
feature so I'll stop here
the code is available over here under my
github there is a blog post series that
walks through what I talked about in a
little more detail on our website if you
want to take a look at that and I'll
take any other questions thank you yes
some procedures naturally very bad do
you think it's reflecting equally on
sorry sir in favor of the common
procedures I'm not understand can you
repeat the question sure yes so for
instance some procedure doesn't appear
differently
yeah because those communites why aren't
some other ones it's very rarely
happening the instance of those
procedures those codes appear in your
nature is much crap unknown frequency do
you think this approach in terms of
fraud like if somebody does too many of
these particular procedures so the way
we use it with the counts I mean I guess
I guess it depends right but the way we
use did we use the counts only for
similarity so if you have one doctor
that has much higher of a particular CPT
code versus the let's say I'm a
cardiologist most of us have five CPT
codes and they all have roughly a
hundred plus minus twenty in the numbers
and one of the I'm the cardiologist has
a ten thousand for example so I would
not look as similar to most of my peers
right I would especially with cost and
simulated it'll actually probably
control the the the strength of the
similarity code and therefore I will
look less I will look more similar to
other specialties and that's how I think
it will get reflected right so even
though I'm a cardiologist if I do
something a little bit more it's not the
original intent of the anomalies we'll
find but I think you'll in some sense
you will find that as well and if you
use a different way to compute
similarity like to don't use similarity
cost and similar to use some other
function you can build a different
similarity function I think to address
that particular problem a little bit
better
I think he might be including well good
question the question was what can we
put the billing information into that so
I would say originally I thought that
that's a good idea
and I was when I gave this talk the
first time I said that that's something
that people should try I'm not sure
about that anymore I think the reason
with billing information is that this is
more of a practical not a mathematical
problem but a lot of billing information
is tied to contracts the doctors have
with the insurance and so a lot of the
anomalies that happen is just because
you're in a different contract or a
different billing arrangement so you
might get skewed results in your
similarity because of that I think in a
number of times you did the procedure is
a much better way to to show similarity
I thought that billing would be really
really informative in the beginning and
I think I kind of concluded later on
that's not that make sense
decade ago monitor and we're usually
company all your pain it means it's
Canada it's not really offensive twice
over payment right and all these things
are not automatic fraud is like
everything goes to a human to review but
you want to flag either of you know
billion claims you want to flag the most
ones that you want to look at so I think
billing information might be I mean I
think we're maybe you're suggesting is
maybe we take the amount claimed in the
amount received and and make the
difference as a part so maybe something
like that I haven't tried it but it's a
good idea yes what is it may be
different for depending on the content
yes I have the contract information so
you can normalize for that yes it's good
that we would it be even possible to
compile that information
I think it's a reasonable idea to try
it's hard for me to say if it'd make it
better or not it could be that the count
and the values and the contract
information and something else will be
the ideal solution but I don't have this
information and so it's hard for me to
give you a finalized answer but I think
it's a good it's a good idea so they
know what yes yeah you know the it's all
the do a rule is safe the the difference
is above $30,000 they build $29.99 all
right I mean it's like of course they do
that it's always like this
yes other questions okay well thank you
really appreciate your time